>> Reporter: THERE HAVE NOT BEEN
CONCESSIONS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION, AT LEAST NOT
YET.
>> Sean: NOT ONE, THAT'S RIGHT.
ED HENRY, THANK YOU.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED OUT ABOUT
THE FBI SCANDAL CONTROVERSY
WHERE, QUOTE, IF THE PERSON
PLAYS VERY EARLY INTO MY
CAMPAIGN WASN'T A SPY, PUT THERE
BY PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES, HOW COME
SUCH A SEEMINGLY MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF MONEY WAS PAID FOR SERVICES
RENDERED, MANY TIMES HIGHER THAN
NORMAL.
FOLLOW THE MONEY.
THE SPY WAS THERE EARLY IN THE
CAMPAIGN YET NEVER REPORTED
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
HE WAS ONLY THERE TO SPY FOR
POLITICAL REASONS AND HELP
CROOKED HILLARY WIN, JUST LIKE
THEY DID TO POOR BERNIE SANDERS
WHO GOT DUPED.
SO TRUE.
JOINING US WITH REACTION,
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN.
BERNIE SANDERS, WHOLE THING WAS
RIGGED.
JIM, JORDAN, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
NUMBER ONE, YOUR LETTER.
THERE ARE 100 KINGMEN THAT WANT
YOU TO BE SPEAKER.
FRANKLY, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE YOU
BE THE NEXT SPEAKER.
>> IF AND WHEN THERE'S A RACE, I
PLAN ON BEING PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION.
WE NEED TO STAY IN MAJORITY AND
HELP DONALD TRUMP ACCOMPLISHED
THE THINGS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ELECTED US TO DO.
THAT'S WHAT I'M FOCUSED ON
DOING.
>> Sean: I HAVE ZERO FAITH IN
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND THE DOJ TO
ACTUALLY HAND OVER THE DOCUMENTS
BECAUSE WE KNOW SPECIFIC
DOCUMENTS WILL BE ABSOLUTELY
DAMNING IF THEY COME OUT AGAINST
THESE VERY PEOPLE.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT TO
THEMSELVES?
>> WELL, SEAN, THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I DON'T BELIEVE AT
THE UPCOMING MEETING THE
CHAIRMAN NUNES IS HAVING WITH
MEMBERS OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, THAT THERE WILL BE
ANY PRODUCTION OF DOCUMENTS.
AND THAT'S DEEPLY CONCERNING TO
ME.
IF YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
SCOREBOARD, RIGHT NOW THE DEEP
STATE IS WINNING THE BATTLE
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN FULL CONTROL
OF THEIR OWN DESTINY.
THAT'S WHY CONGRESSMAN LEE
ZELLDEN AND JIM JORDAN JOINED
WITH TWO DOZEN COLLEAGUES TO
CALL FOR A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
>> Sean: IS THAT THE BEST WAY,
THOUGH?
>> ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
>> Sean: WELL, THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S RIDICULOUS.
18 MONTHS INTO THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF TIME.
>> SEAN, THIS WILL BE A REASON
FOR THEM TO DELAY THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT.
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE BACK IN
INSPECTOR GENERAL LAND AND SO
NOW WE WON'T GET THE ANSWERS ON
HILLARY CLINTON --
>> Sean: WELL, HE SAID IT
SEPARATE AND AAPART.
THAT'S BEEN HANDED OVER.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, THOUGH.
WE HAVE FISA ABUSE.
WE KNOW OUTRIGHT JUDGES WERE
LIED TO IN LITERALLY THE SINGLE
BIGGEST INTRUSION INTO A
PERSON'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS,
A FISA WARRANT.
FOUR TIMES THEY LIED, THE BULK
OF INFORMATION, THAT PHONY
DOSSIER.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE JUDGE WHO
PAID FOR IT OR JUDGES.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SAYS, DON'T WORRY, WE CAN
INVESTIGATE OURSELVES EVEN
THOUGH, AS YOU SAY, THEY TOOK A
DOSSIER TO A SECRET COURT TO GET
A WARRANT.
DIDN'T TELL THE COURT THAT THE
AUTHOR OF THE DOCUMENT,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, HAD BEEN
FIRED.
EVEN THOUGH IT NOW APPEARS THERE
WERE PAID INFORMANTS HANGING
AROUND THE PERIPHERY OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: THINK OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
SPIED ON THE CAMPAIGN, LYING TO
JUDGES TO GET FISA WARRANTS TO
SPY ON AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE WITH PROPAGANDA FROM
RUSSIA PUT TOGETHER BY A FOREIGN
NATIONAL THAT WAS FULL OF LIES
AND LITERALLY THEY DON'T TELL
THE JUDGES.
I CANNOT BELIEVE -- I WOULDN'T
WRITE THIS IN A SPY NOVEL,
BECAUSE I WOULDN'T THINK ANYBODY
WOULD BELIEVE IT.
>> JEFF SESSIONS SAYS ONLY UNDER
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES DO
YOU NAME A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
HOW ABOUT THE FACT THE TOP FIVE
PEOPLE AT THE FBI HAVE BEEN
FIRED OR DEMOTED.
THOSE SAME PEOPLE THAT RAN THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION, WHO
LAUNCHED THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, WHO USED THE
OPPOSITION RESEARCH DOCUMENT AT
THE FISA COURT AND NOW LOOK LIKE
PAID INFORMANTS TO BE A PART OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HOW ABOUT THAT FOR A FACT
PATTERN THAT'S EXTRAORDINARY?
IF THAT'S NOT EXTRAORDINARY,
SOMEONE BETTER TELL ME WHAT IS.
>> THAT'S WHY JIM JORDAN SHOULD
BE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, THEN
WE'D HAVE REAL OVERSIGHT.
>> Sean: CHECKMATE.